est-ce que déjà vous pouvez évaluer
votre saison sur une échelle de 1 à 10
alors en étant honnête je dirais 6
au dessus de la moyenne
oui parce que je suis extrêmement
sympathique
et j'apporte beaucoup ne pas présence il
est vrai que je menace un peu j'ai
toujours peur de l'épuisement des
ressources mentales surtout que chez
vous ça va vite
elles sont vite épuisées effectivement
je connais ouais donc c'est pour ça que
je suis d'un calme Olympia mais je suis
là c'est pas plutôt parce que vous
n'avez rien à dire c'est bien passé
traduit différemment
surtout
en fait je m'en fous voilà
est-ce que vous venez ici juste
pour prendre votre cachet et pouvoir
faire des UV à volonté
qui vous l'a dit alors c'est ça ou pas
est-ce que si demain je te dis voilà
Bernard tu viens mais tu viens
bénévolement est-ce que tu viendrais
[Rires]
et si je te dis oui je suis obligé de
réduire les salaires ben non ben non non
plus j'ai des frais moi monsieur et si
je te dis j'ai plusieurs voitures
plusieurs maisons 50%
[Rires]
parce que en fait j'ai essayé de te
mettre au niveau qui est ce que je veux
[Rires]
un problème si vous voulez mettre un bon
niveau non moi je me suis toujours sur
évalué voyez c'est beaucoup plus malin
vous savez quand on travaille quand on
voit son patron comme vous voyez on a
envie de se valoriser etc vous vous
savez la valeur que j'ai je sais dans
votre regard que vous êtes admiratif
c'est pour ça
tout le temps
j'en ai de l'admiration ah ouais ça ça
me touche d'ailleurs parce que vous
m'avez vu petit garçon j'étais déjà une
star mondiale vous avez pensé allez chez
ophtalmo
je comprends j'ai l'impression que les
gens vous rappelle pour animer une
émission vous y allez ah ouais bien sûr
qui pètent j'ai déjà fait pendant 14 ans
je peux le refaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que vous trouvez que vous êtes le
meilleur pour animer le 6 à 7
alors cette embarrassant mais c'est vrai
c'est embarrassant parce que c'est vrai
que je fais de meilleurs scores
[Rires]
arades mais je les aime tellement que je
veux pas qu'ils se blesse c'est vous qui
faites les meilleures questions
[Applaudissements]
ça fait pas plaisir de le dire mais je
vais vous dire je vais appeler je vais
appeler Vincent Pujol le directeur des
programmes
c'est oui et parce que moi après vous
délire que c'est moi mais il va le dire
la vérité sérieux en plus
directeur et dit la vérité je veux
vraiment que tu dises la vérité une pas
de vanne ni rien ça va c'est les
meilleurs audiences du 6 à 7 Castaldi
Benaim dit la vérité alors tu veux que
je dise la vérité ou tu veux que je dise
la vérité que tu as envie d'entendre
la vérité et après tu diras la vérité
que j'ai envie d'entendre
la vérité la vérité la vérité et je sais
que Bernard est face à toi pour moi
celui qui fait les meilleurs audiences
c'est Bernard
[Applaudissements]
il est sur les chiffres il est
incroyable et vous l'entendre
ça veut dire ça veut dire Bernard que la
vérité que Cyril a envie d'entendre
soit
ben d'ailleurs de devant Ada peut-être
les meilleurs audiences mais il faut
gagner le combat d'après c'est ça la
vérité il a pas de combat d'après assis
tu comptes pas revenir l'année prochaine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je t'embrasse mon Vincent bon gros
bisous
merci
j'ai plus rien à vous dire super
[Applaudissements]